uns wird omicron so mitte januar ende
januar wenn nichts weiter geschieht als
das was bisher geschehen ist
richtig richtig hart treffen mit einer
impfung und boostern werden wir diese
diese welle die jetzt unmittelbar
bevorsteht nicht aufhalten wenn jetzt
den ganzen winter einfach durchkämpfen
müssen und das ist glaube ich hat
schlimme verliert ein fachleute des
kindinger und irgendwie verlieren
personal wir sind eigentlich jetzt schon
wieder in anspannung was da auf uns
zukommen wird und
lust hat keiner mehr die fünfte welle
da graut es allen absolut denn sie sind
müde und ausgelaugt nach knapp zwei
jahren kann den oberarzt matthias reichl
ist wie alle hier permanent im einsatz
auf der kuh wie die intensivstation des
klinikums mühldorf und das was wir
befürchtet haben oder was wir zusammen
was eindruck ist immer passiert es ist
jedes mal wieder schneller geworden weil
es jetzt kommt die nächste variante der
schritt von schauen ja die vierte welle
ist noch nicht vorbei da drohten und
micon und das macht würde
und nicht nichts
so
ein selbstläufer den dem thema immer
hinterherlaufen muss
doch ein ende es ist hier nicht in sicht
und die szenarien der vergangenen wochen
als die schwerkranke menschen verlegen
mussten weil es kein platz mehr für sie
gab als alle an ihr limit kamen diese
bilder sind allzu präsent wir hatten die
situation vor sechs wochen das war
unglaublich belastbar da wir hatten auch
unterstützungskräfte von der bundeswehr
die konnten teilweise nicht mehr werden
pflegekräfte die waren so fertig diesen
auf dem gang und haben geweint weil das
so anstrengend war von diesen eindrücken
konnte sich das team in der klinik kaum
erholen denn die arbeit läuft weiter
schäfer zimmermann studiert das ct einer
frau anfang 40 die prozent kam mit
wirklich schwerster atemnot hat keine
schweren vorerkrankungen aber das zeigt
eben halt auch wie tückisch dieses virus
ist dass sie überleben wird daran gab es
zunächst zweifel das sind ja schon sehr
schwer wiegen gelungene veränderung dass
wir da ist so gut durchgekommen sind
also es eigentlich schon drücken im
frühjahr war sie erstmals ein corona
erkrankt so die patientin nicht erkannt
werden möchte jetzt habe sie sich erneut
angesteckt bei einem ihrer kinder alle
sind ungeimpft warum meine kinder und
ich können nicht geimpft werden denn
meine lebensgeschichte hat sehr viel
schwierigkeiten welche darüber will sie
nicht sprechen was sie gerettet habe
gott eindeutig im operationsbereich
stehen die meisten seele leer nur im
äußersten notfall wenn ein intensiv wird
frei ist wird operiert denn das personal
wird auf den kurven intensivstationen
benötigt seit wochen das hat auch renate
richter zu spüren bekommen die
56-jährige hat lungenkrebs ihre op
musste immer wieder verschoben werden
wissens wird sie zu hause sitzen kaum
mehr atmen können und sich ihren platz
in einem krankenhaus eine für sie
lebensnotwendige operation große die
verstehen das verfolgt sieht aber noch
es wird in kauf genommen dass sie stirbt
ich wünsche es keine
es geht ihr gut am tag zuvor wurde sie
operiert morgens in der früh kam die
nachricht nur wenige stunden später die
op die ärzte sind mit ihrem ergebnis
sehr zufrieden die situation für schwer
kranke patienten insgesamt sei
allerdings katastrophal dass der patient
zu hause aus den termin wartet dass wir
den patienten sagen er solle nüchtern
bleiben weil sollte sich ein intensiv
bett für den tag ergeben bestellen wir
in einer und operieren ihn noch am
gleichen tag das sind endlich zustände
die eigentlich für behandler genauso wie
für patienten unerträglich sei
der druck im haus durch die korona
pandemie überall ist er spürbar auch
beim pflegepersonal auf den normalen
stationen
patienten durchlauf schon so hoch und
die arbeitsbelastung ist es hektik und
stress und hektik und stress macht mir
einfach viele
fehler die man sich nicht leisten kann
andrea thalhammer unternimmt alles um
ihre teamkolleginnen zu unterstützen
doch auch bei ihr ist die vorherrschende
stimmung einfach enttäuschung und oft
auch resignation also ich bin ja ich
arbeite jetzt sagen es ist auch für die
patienten
sehr schlecht weil die brauchen einfach
empathie und man muss ja selber gut
drauf sei und säurefrei und hellem kopf
und frisch damit die patienten gut
versorgt werden die arbeit belastet alle
hier auf allen stationen nach wie vor
auch erfahrene intensivmediziner wie
martin kahl wenn man das elend gesehen
hat wenn man die den tod gesehen haben
zwar massenhaft gesehen hat wenn
familienangehörigen nebeneinander auf
der intensivstation lagen und der eine
ist gestorben
der andere hat überlebt
das sind momente wo das ein nahe geht
ein ausnahmezustand der medizin längst
ist eher die regel hohe infektionszahlen
hohe inzidenz im vergleich zu den ersten
wählen wie lebt der mediziner damit wenn
wir das noch mal eine weile ertragen und
noch mal eine weile ertragen so werden
wir jedes mal fähige mitarbeiter
verlieren die diesen stress so nicht
mehr mitmachen
eine folge viele mitarbeiter verlassen
die klinik neue kräfte schwierig
intensivpfleger roland eltern ging vor
jahren in rente noch vor kurzem war er
seine ehemaligen kollegen nicht hängen
lassen wollte ist der 64 hier wird
zurückgekehrt trotz großer bedenken
als ich dann im letzten jahr losgehen
kam bei mir persönlich wirklich schon
auch mit die angst ins spiel
es ist ja so wenn wir hier dienste haben
dann kann man nicht sagen tut mir nichts
an mache ich nicht da muss mehr rein
arbeiten ganz nah wie patienten trotz
der angst sich in seine familie
anzustecken und nicht zu wissen wie sich
das ganze entwickeln wird wie jetzt bei
omikron der aktuellen virusvariante
natürlich hofft man jetzt das bleibt der
letzte strohhalm dass die impfung
funktioniert dass das bus dann
funktioniert dieser strohhalm an dem
halt ganz fest so lange wie es geht im
labor der klinik werden unter anderem
auch die kurve tests durchgeführt als
hygienebeauftragte ist oberarzt thomas
panitzke auch dafür zuständig nur weil
die vierte welle abflaut so der
mediziner sei das infektionsgeschehen
noch lange nicht vorbei wir schauen im
moment zu
wie jeden tag ein jumbo-jet über
deutschland abstürzen
so viele menschen sterben
und wir haben uns daran gewöhnt das ist
tatsächlich einfach eine frage der
gewöhnung wo haben wir uns zum glück
hier in der klinik nicht gehören ist
einzelne fälle die uns alle sehr
betroffen machen
knapp 1800 patienten wurden seit beginn
der pandemie in mutter versorgt und 270
auf intensiv und 300 menschen sind an
und mit cupid gestorben nüchterne zahlen
die gravierende spuren hinterlassen bei
allen ich denke dass wir ein stück
normalität und leichtigkeit tatsächlich
verloren haben und ich glaube auch nicht
dass wir sie so schnell zurückbekommen
und sie wappnen sich im im klinikum
mühldorf für eine mögliche neue welle